on a tuesday night in the bronx
corey kluber is going to tow the slab
and the boogie down you can see those
numbers
progressively have gotten a lot better
in the scouting report the breaking ball
package is a lead again michael i mean
that no-hitter he threw 19 of them 12
were called strikes seven were swung and
missed
2-2
swinging and a miss
one away
swing and a miss besheck down on strikes
two-way
the pitch swung on
a high pop
on the left side of the infield geo
waiting for it he makes a catch
and so kluber
[Applause]
has a no-hitter after one yeah and
steven matt's making his 10th start of
the season the yankees have been very
good scoring runs in the first inning
this season and steven matz has yet to
give up a first inning run so he's
looking to continue that streak the
yankees have scored 18 first inning runs
in the last 25 games
3-2 swing and a miss got it with a
fastball over the outside corner one
down
2-2 swing and a miss missed his spot but
got a fastball by torres just like he
did voip
well steven matz has great stuff and his
fastball has a lot of late movement and
you're right you could see the target by
danny jansen was down and in but when
you have that kind of life and velocity
on your pitches you can make mistakes
three two and he got him great change up
down below the knees and stephen matt
strikes out the side in the bottom of
the first so a lead off base hit for the
yankees in the bottom of the second in
this scoreless game and now it'll be
gary sanchez who is d.h
runner but first nobody out and a
fastball swung on and miss he gets
sanchez for the first down
one two and did he go they appeal down
to third
and
he
we haven't seen it he did not i guess he
is staying at the box now he's walking
back to the dugout so i don't know if he
was having a
conversation or not but yes he did go
around and odor strikes out that's two
down and five strikeouts already for
matt's one on one out
no score top three and here's guerrero
he drills a ball right center field and
it is gone
he has done it again
and he is all alone atop the major
league home run leaderboard right now
number 16 for vladi and it's two to
nothing blue jays it wasn't the pitch he
was looking for and gets a breaking ball
out over the plate and drills it to deep
right field
boy is he hot
42 ribbies now for vlady that's the
story
corey kluber who struck out five and
three and he's gave up a two-run home
run to vlad guerrero is out of the game
he exited tonight's game with tightness
in his right shoulder he will undergo
additional tests now lourdes gorilla jr
who bounced into a fielder's choice his
first time up 2-2
and now he drives the ball to right
center field this one is pretty well hit
off the top of the wall
and it is gone it evidently hit
something behind the wall and it's a
home run
for guerrielle
gardner saw it right away he must have
hit that bench behind the padded wall
and that's a homer for goriel to make it
three to nothing blue jays
fourth homer of the season and yeah
you're right there's brett gardner was
standing right there and he didn't act
as if it hit the top of the fence he
acted as if it hit something beyond the
fence because he just
caught it nonchalantly and didn't even
think about throwing it back to the
infield so guriel
continues to show signs that he's gonna
heat it up a little bit another opposite
field home run guerrero and guriel both
driving pitches to the opposite field
and again that's the that's a way to get
it out at yankee stadium
first base open wow i know hernandez is
tough on deck as well
yeah use your head
and they make the right decision as
urchella fields and fires it
king works out of a big jam the bases
are loaded with one down three nothing
blue jays top seven and now with a lefty
on the mound for the yankees
the right hand hitting santiago espinal
will come up to pinch hit for joe panic
big big spot for espinal right here this
they've had so many
chances two-two and a swing and a ground
ball in the hole at short throwhole
skips past higashiyoka
gretchek in to score tolezin behind him
guriel to third espanol to second and it
is five to nothing
torres trying to get the force out at
home
and that would have been a terrific play
he goes into the hole throws on the run
and agashiok is stretching like a first
baseman couldn't come up with it you got
to push these guys you know everybody's
so conscientious about the pitch count
now but these guys are terrific athletes
they're in great shape and there's no
sign of any wear and tear or fatigue
and he got him swinging strikes out odor
for the third time tonight two down in
the bottom of the seventh so they send
the pitching coach pete walker out to
talk with mats
which means they're going to push him a
little bit more
to get kyle hikashioka
that one's ripped down the left field
line it's a fair ball it goes into the
corner frazier will score higashiyoga
will stop it first with an rbi single
yankees on the board in 5-1 toronto
he will leave the ballgame with a
runnerous second around in six and
two-thirds for stephen mats
here is guerrero
guerrero hits a ground ball at the third
o'shella back hands throws his second in
the fourth back to first double play
as good a double play as you'll ever see
ashela of course started it a backhander
his he backhanded the ball on the line
his momentum took him over the line as
he threw the second and odor who can
really turn it and fire the first
randall griczyk will lead off the ninth
for the blue jays
the 2-0 to grichik well hit ball left
center field and it's gonna go
grichik with his ninth home run of the
season and the blue chase now leads six
to one third homerun of the night for
the blue jays and they continue to pound
out the homers vlady guerrero junior had
a two-run shot guerrilla had an opposite
field solo home run and now randall
richard connects
dan mentioned his ninth of the season
that gives him 37 rbis and this is a
very balanced attack
line drive in the left center field it's
a base hit
odor
will round third as the ball is bubbled
out in left field odor will
ending up in second is hikashioka the
yankees still alive at 6-2 blue jays and
it is six to two rutherford second two
down number nine hitter brett gardner
one two on the way fastball and a swing
and a miss to get him and romano
finishes off the yankees by striking out
gardner